hi guys welcome to this video on Nagios
interview questions and answers Nagios
or Nagios core it's a free open-source
computer software that is used to
monitor systems networks and
infrastructure Nagios was initially
released in 2002 and since then has
become the go-to solution for monitoring
in the DevOps lifecycle in this video we
have compiled the most important Nagios
interview questions that you might face
in the Nagios or DevOps interview so
without further ado let's get started so
let's look at continuous monitoring so
with continuous monitoring how does that
give us help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and service and so
this is really just a high-level
question of using new years within your
environment and you should be able to
just come back very quickly and say
Negus allows you to help manage this
service and check if they've been
sufficiently utilized and if there are
any tasks failures that need to be
addressed and so there are three areas
of utilization and risk that you want to
be able to manage this is being able to
verify the status and services of the
entire network the health of your
infrastructure as a whole and in
applications are working properly
together with our web services and api's
that are reachable so the second
question you'll be asked is how does
Negus help in continuous monitoring of
systems applications and services so
it's able to do this by having the
initial venegas process and scheduler
and the additional plugins that you
would use for your network connect with
the remote resources and the negative
web interface to be able to run status
checks on a predefined schedule so what
do you mean by nagging us remote
plugging executor or the mpre of nine
years so mpre
allows you to execute plugins on lengths
UNIX machines that allow you to do
additional monitoring and machine
metrics such as disk usage CPU load etc
what are the ports used by Nagios for
monitoring purposes in this example
there are three and they're easy to
remember so I would
memorize these three but they're
essentially ports five six six six five
six six seven and five six six eight so
there are two types of checks within a
year so you will be asked for what is an
active and passive check in nine years
so an active check and is initiated by
the Nagios process and is run on a
regular schedule a passive check is
initiated and formed by an external
application or process since maybe where
a system is failing and checks our
results are submitted to now years for
processing and to continue with this for
what is an active and passive check
active checks are initiated by the check
logic within the nanos daemon Negus will
execute a plug-in and pass information
about what needs to be checked plugin
will then check the operational state of
the host of service and then will
process the results of the host or
service check and send out notifications
in contrast with the passive check it is
an external application that initiates
the check it writes the results of the
check to an external command line file
Negus reads the external command file
and places a results of all passive
checks in a queue for later processing
so you can go back and revalidate and
then- may send out notifications log
alerts etc depending on the results that
they get from checking the information
so you're gonna be asked to explain the
main configuration file and its location
in New Year so the main configuration
file consists of a number of directives
that affect how neno's operates so
consider this as the configuration file
that's read by both now your processor
and the CGI's so this will allow you to
be able to manage the main configuration
file that is placed into your settings
directory so what is the negative
network analyzer and again hold out your
four fingers because there are four
options here so the Nagios network
analyzer r1 provides an in-depth look at
all your network traffic source and
security threads to allows system admins
together high-level information on the
health of your network 3 provides a
central view of your network traffic and
bandwidth data and then 4 allows you to
proactive in resolving outages
normal behavior and threats before they
affect critical business processes so
what are the benefits of HTTP and SSL
certificate monitoring's with Nagios so
with HTTP certificate monitoring it
allows you to have increased server and
services and application availability
obviously very important fast attention
of network outages and protocol failures
and allows web transaction and web
service performance monitoring the SSL
certificate monitoring allows you for
increased website availability frequent
application availability and provides
increased security so explained
virtualization with Nagios so in
response the first thing you should be
able to talk about is how Negus itself
can run on many different virtualization
platforms including Microsoft Visual PC
VMware Zen Amazon ec2 etc etc so just
make sure you get that right off the bat
negative it was able to provide
capabilities tomorrow and so much of
metrics on different platforms it allows
for ensure for quick detection of
service and application failures and has
the ability to be able to monitor
against many metrics including CPU usage
memory networking and VM status so name
the three variables that affect
recursion inheritance in new years and
it is named use and register so name is
a template name that can be referenced
in other object definitions use
specifies the name of the template
object that you want to inherit its
properties of variables from and
register indicates whether or not the
object definition should be registered
to dag yes and on the right-hand side of
the screen we have an example of what
that script would look like again you
may want to be able to memorize this as
it's something that you can achieve
write down and show someone if you're
going through a technical interview so
why is nanyo said to be object-oriented
and fundamentally comes down to the
object configuration format you can use
in your object definitions it allows you
to inherit properties from other object
definitions and this is typical
object-oriented development and is now
applied for the Nagios environment so
some of the objects that you can inherit
our services host
commands and time periods so finally
explain what is state talking in nine
years and so there are really four
options here when you're talking about
States talking so States talking is used
for logging purposes in Nagios it allows
you to enable for a particular host or
service that negatives will watch over
very carefully it will log any changes
it sees in the output of the check
results and then finally helps the
analysis of log files thanks guys
with that we've reached the end of this
Nagios interview questions video I hope
you enjoyed this video do like and share
it thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from Sam Keylong hi there if
you like this video subscribe to the
simple learn youtube channel and click
here to watch similar videos standard up
and get certified click here